this goat made a hearty meal for a
cheetah last night but there's even
enough left to feed the village this
evening
max muyamburuku and his team have come
to the village where it was killed in
the muduva nyangana conservancy they log
all events concerning wild animals here
previously hunters they were setting
snail for leipert
and tea for hyena if it kills a
goat or calf they will put their snails
so that they can kill that aina or
leopard
this is no longer allowed but poaching
is still a widespread problem especially
with wire snares
the rangers see this all too often
that is
another challenge that we are facing
some
are not really conserving but due to
hunger they are doing it so that they
can feed themselves
the conservancy is part of casa tfca the
kavango zambezi trans frontier
conservation area
casa is an international project
spanning namibia and its neighboring
countries it's the largest protected
area in africa more than seventeen
hundred people live here most of them
farmers like licoro cashera
things have changed here since we became
part of the casa program
since then we've lost more crops because
the population of the wild animals has
grown
and our cows have less land to graze on
because the wild animals need to graze
too there's more competition
but the farmers are compensated if
elephants destroy their crops
there are also hunting lodges in the
park trophy hunting brings in a lot of
money it's still an important source of
income for the community the hunters
don't want to talk on camera
muduva nyangana covers an area of over
600 square kilometers and is constantly
patrolled
despite the hunting the main aim here is
to protect the wild animals as well as
namibia the kaza program also covers
areas of botswana angola zambia and
zimbabwe
the countries have also agreed to leave
transnational migration routes open for
wildlife
casa also encompasses the ocovango delta
a unesco world heritage site in northern
botswana
the largest tributary is the kavango
river that flows from angola through
northeastern namibia and into the delta
where it forms a rich biodiverse wetland
the kavango always carries water so it's
of huge importance to the people here
in the dry season there's often a
shortage of water because the smaller
rivers dry up
and residents fear that water could
become even scarcer because canadian
company recon africa has just begun test
drilling here for oil and gas the
namibian government has a 10 stake in it
and not everything is above board
legally speaking
an environmental report was only
submitted after the fact and the
resident's concerns were not taken into
account
neither recon africa nor the government
were willing to talk to deutsche welle
test drilling has so far only taken
place in the muduva nyangana conservancy
a lot of water has been used in the
process and residents are now worried
that the drilling might have
contaminated their water supply
pressured by the community recon africa
did take water samples
but six months later there are still no
results
there is a lot of mistrust towards the
drilling company
we want an independent company to come
and test the water
some pollution in the water that's
related to their activity
and isn't telling us about it
it would be better if an independent
company came and did the tests
however environmental activists and the
affected communities have enjoyed some
success they joined forces and their
voices have been heard but still too
little has changed says max muyamuruku
and he fears there will be far-reaching
consequences
if the oil production will start
a
will start in the the kavango area
we are also going to
step in the footprint for
in nigeria where they are suffering
because of pollution from oil
or pollution from gas and the
environment will be
destroyed the air pollution also will be
destroyed
the air will be polluted the underground
water the river everything will be
contaminated
many residents believe they can profit
far more from nature conservation and
tourism than from oil
the outbreak of the virus we're dealing
with now has had a detrimental effect on
tourism because hardly any visitors come
here
before the pandemic we were at least
surviving because we were getting money
from the conservancy
and the program had great plans for the
future everyone here might soon be
getting regular payment from the program
rangers and communities plan to keep
fighting oil exploration in the country
max muyamburuku believes they need to
put a stop to it once and for all it's
the only way in the long run to protect
the unique nature of kavango
you